[Music]
now
next week the government will seek to
renew its emergency covert powers
for another six months even though the
vaccine rollout continues on target
hospitalizations and deaths are
collapsing and in three months
the final covert restrictions are
expected to go in england
so why the need for emergency powers
through to the autumn
i'll be speaking shortly to jonathan
assumption but first
let's go to kate andrews our economics
correspondent she edits the spectator's
daily lunchtime briefing which contains
all that you need to know
about each day's latest covert news kate
over to you thanks andrew as you say
mps are set to debate and extend the
emergency powers before the easter break
and this has prompted a deep dive into
the data to look at how we're really
tackling covet 19 in the uk at the
moment
as you can see from this first slide the
seven day average for infections has
been on a steady decline
now sitting around where infections were
in early to mid september last year
and here in the second slide you can see
that hospitalizations
are on an even steeper decline and this
is looking at the number of patients
admitted to hospital
which is now down to where it was in
early october
and this has certainly been helped by
the vaccine rollout which is preventing
not just against catching covet 19 but
of course serious reactions to the virus
which can lead to hospitalization and
sadly death
although if we look at this third chart
here deaths again clearly
in a steady decline as well with the
seven day average now reflecting where
we were in early to mid october last
year
as well now sadly this is not the story
that is reflected everywhere else the uk
as you can see from this next chart has
one of the lowest case rates in europe
this week italy put much of the country
back into red zones a very restrictive
form of lockdown as another wave hits
france is expected to extend lockdown
measures into the paris region in the
days to come
and the czech republic has even been
relying on hospi on the hospital
capacity of other countries
to treat their patients now much of what
is behind this
is europe's struggle with their vaccine
rollout
and you can see from this last slide
that the uk continues not just to be a
leader in europe
but a leader worldwide when it comes to
this jab race
there were worrying indications
yesterday that we may be looking at a
slowdown
of our vaccine rate in in the month
ahead a reminder that the story is far
from over
but when we're debating the
extraordinary government powers
you can see how one could certainly make
the case that
parts of europe are experiencing a state
of emergency but that argument is
becoming much more
difficult to make here in the uk at
least right now
back to you andrew thanks kate it's kind
of a striking graph there of uh
between britain and the rest of the
other european
union countries up tell us a bit more if
you can about
this uh astro zenica vaccine shortage if
it is a vaccine shortage
some sort of scale stories in the london
papers this morning
i think in short andrew yes it is a bit
worrying we got this leaked letter
yesterday from nhs england to local
vaccine suppliers
saying that they were expecting supply
to be more limited in the month ahead
and it's thought that part of the reason
for this is a delay in getting roughly 5
million doses of astrazeneca
from india that there's been a delay on
the export
from india and which is disappointing
news especially for those who haven't
had their first job yet because
in this letter it states that there
should be a pause on
offering people appointments to get
their first jab although it's insistent
if you've had your first job
you shouldn't worry your second one is
still coming now ministers have been
quick to say that this is just part of
the process that the vaccine rollout is
going to have its peaks and troughs and
people shouldn't be worried
um and they're also insistent that their
deadlines are they're sticking to when
it comes to
uh the top nine most vulnerable
categories of people being inoculated by
the 15th of april
and then for all adults to have gotten
their first job by the end of july but i
do think this is an important reminder
that while things are going so well and
as you saw in that
chart about the vaccine race the uk
really is a world leader and
the race is not over we are still going
and there's still
many hurdles that we have to overcome so
unfortunately it looks like there could
be a bit of a slowdown in april
but other vaccines are expected to come
online in the spring
we don't have specific details yet but
we should be looking at the moderna
vaccine
hopefully in the near future so things
could pick up as well
well there are a lot of european
countries sitting on a huge batch of
astrozenica vaccine that they say they
don't want
to use because they think it doesn't
work very well
can we not just get them to send over
the stuff they don't want
yeah this is becoming a bit of a circus
in the european union
for months now you have had ursula van
der lion and you've had
major european leaders undermining
confidence in the astrosenica vaccine
and indeed in the uk's rollout of
vaccines full stop suggesting that
our nimble regulator perhaps skipped
over some
safety precautions for which there is
absolutely no evidence
you had germany you had france
suggesting i think it was macron said
that the
vaccine was quasi-effective for the over
65s again
no evidence for this and now we're in a
very strange
strange position where many of these eu
countries are on the one
hand complaining that astrazeneca hasn't
been giving them the supplies that were
promised
and they're in a rage about this and
then on the other hand uh suggesting
that they have to pause this vaccine
because they're not sure
about the safety standards what i would
say in defense
of the eu is that the european medicines
agency
is adamant that this vaccine is safe and
that it should be administered
to all of the adult age groups and
they're pleading with
european countries to start up the
rollout of astrazeneca again if it's
been paused so
in many cases it's not the eu although
there have been moments i think from
from leaders in the eu that have
undermined this process
but individual european leaders and it's
frustrating because
it seems political in many of these
circumstances it
it just seems like they're following
they're getting in line
following one after the next following
what their neighbors are doing but it
isn't necessarily in the best interest
of the nations
the problem is that even if the european
medical authorities say it's okay
and everybody expects that that's
exactly what they're going to do
i'm afraid chancellor merkel and
president macron have poisoned the well
opinion polls in france for example show
that there's a substantial
minority of uh french people who just
won't take astrazeneca
uh now i mean they they will not find
this easy kate to roll back
uh they they have uh already changed
public opinion and public opinion won't
dance to their tune now i think it's a
as europe is hit by a third wave as your
figures show
this is a real crisis for europe i would
suggest i
fear deeply andrew that people who are
vulnerable to this virus people who can
end up in hospitalization
even sadly end up dead from this virus
may be put off getting the vaccine
because of what these major european
leaders have said i think you're right
it's very hard to roll back now because
it's not the first instance that they've
done it they've been doing it for months
[Music]
you